mr. speaker I agree with my honorable
friend of course the UK government wants
to work closely with the Scottish
government this these statistics that
were released last week are shocking to
everyone in Scotland and indeed
throughout the United Kingdom but it
shouldn't be suggested that any of the
policy issues with the UK government are
the sole answer to this issue it is
complex and the powers that the Scottish
Parliament already has will go a long
way to dealing with it two weeks ago my
constituent Chelsea Bruce died in a
drugs related incident she was just 16
years old mr. speaker the time for hand
wringing is over we know that drug
consumption rooms drop and testing and
even see if clinical prescribing of
illicit drugs will save lives the
international body of evidence is
unequivocal but yet the Secretary of
State has been skeptical and vague on
this if only it would show some
leadership and ultimately finding a
route through the impasse between the
Home Office and the Lord advocate to
help rapidly roll these facilities in
Glasgow and across Scotland mr. speaker
how many more must die before the
Secretary of State recognizes as public
health emergency and acts to save lives
mr. speaker that sort of politicking is
completely unworthy of this a serious a
debate the home office UK government and
I respect the Scottish government take
this issue seriously we are going to
have a summit in early course to discuss
all the issues around that and I hope I
sincerely hope because I have a
constituents die as well that we can
move forward Thank You mr. speaker
question six Mr Speaker I have regular
meetings with my right honourable friend
the prime minister who has been
unwavering in her passionate support for
our Union we have regularly discussed
the UK's government's continued
commitment to the devolution settlement
and her strong Scotland within a strong
United Kingdom but in Whitby of the mr.
speaker the secretary of state is in his
place later what will he do to keep
Scotland in its place in the UK
mr. speaker I will continue to do as I
have done for the past a4i and a bit
years and that is to relentlessly make
the positive case for the benefit of
Scotland being in the United Kingdom and
to the United Kingdom of having Scotland
in it David TC Davis mr. speaker Greg
will be leaving the European Union ah we
do so mr. speaker good he confirmed that
100 extra powers will be devolved to the
Scottish Parliament meaning the
Conservatives and break cities are the
truth Friends of devolution and a strong
Scottish
mr. speaker the point that my honourable
friend a makes is a very pertinent a one
this party this government has been
committed to the devolution settlement
and to making it work there is one party
in this parliament that would destroy
devolution and that is the SNP
servant mr. speaker mr. speaker with
permission I'll answer question seven
and twelve together I've had regular
discussions with the Prime Minister on a
range of matters related to exiting the
EU it is essential that we respect the
result of the 2016 referendum vote to
leave the EU in No Deal brexit combined
with ending free movement of people
which is the inbound by mariscos
prospectus would restate scottish
business and the public sector from
recruiting the staff they need yeah the
Secretary of State was welcomed the
appointment of the inbound
Prime Minister you can we conclude then
he's prepared to throw business and
public services under a bus simply to
protect his own career
mr. speaker what amounts a to throwing
Scotland under a bus has been the
actions of the SNP throughout the brexit
debates in this Parliament voting
against three times an agreement which
would have allowed Scotland to leave the
EU on an orderly basis and largely in
accordance with their own document
Scotland's place in Europe
Douglas Chapman Thank You mr. speaker in
recent weeks I've read the course that
host places in London are falling and
job vacancies cardones
two classic signs of an economy going
into recession and into this the mix of
potential of an ordeal
Boris brexit Bureau given these
circumstances for the sector States
Plan B for the storage economy mr. a
speaker a the incoming Prime Minister
has been very clear that he wants to
leave the EU with a deal and that is the
best outcome for Scotland
so me Shepherd Thank You mr. speaker let
me read this for failure of misquoting
the Secretary of State he told the last
Scottish Conservative Party conference
unfortunately mr. Johnson seems to
behave in a way that suggests he is only
focused on his own self-interest and not
in the interests of our country and I
find that very disappointing
can I ask the Secretary of State has he
now overcome his disappointment and will
he continue to serve the new prime
minister a speaker just like him and his
colleagues everything I am ever said
I want
is that my priority remains scotland's
please within the united kingdom and
that in government are out will be my
continuing priority
Tommy Shepard mr. speaker the hosts will
observe that that is not actually an
answer to my question yeah he sits
beside cabinet colleagues who have
demonstrated integrity and conviction in
deciding that they won't resign over the
question of a No Deal fraction if he is
against a No Deal brexit would it not be
a better look for Scotland for him to do
likewise rather than wait to be site or
abolished now mr. speaker of course the
honourable gentleman's position isn't a
deal brexit or a new deal brexit it's no
brexit that's what he's seeking to bring
about but there is no evidence that the
SNP has at any time been serious about
getting a deal for Scotland on each
occasion they've had the opportunity to
vote for a deal they have voted against
it
finally and briefly Seabury
Mr Speaker I hope that the Secretary of
State stays in his position but
apparently in order to do so he's going
to have to sign the pledge because in
order to serve in the next government
he's got to agree like others that come
October the 31st to a dick to leave me
the EU Deal or No Deal
goodie tell us yes or no will he be the
despatch-box again or are these his mr.
speaker mr. speaker I fear that the
Honorable lady's endorsement will have
sealed my fate
[Applause]
questions to the Prime Minister
Roose Cadbury
mr. mr. speaker this morning I had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others following my duties in this house
this afternoon I shall have an audience
of Her Majesty the Queen I shall then
continue with my duties in this house
from the back benches where I will
continue to be the Member of Parliament
for maid Mary Thank You mr. speaker I
profoundly disagree with many of the
decisions the Prime Minister has made
and many of the things she says but I
recognize that she does have a respect
for public service and for the future of
our country so how does she feel about
handing over to a man who among many
things is happy to demonize Muslims
he's prepared to chuck our loyal public
servants and diplomats under a bus
and promises to sell our country out to
Donald Trump and his friends
I'm I am pleased to hand over to an
incoming leader of the Conservative
Party and prime minister who I worked
with when he was in my cabinet
[Music]
[Applause]
and who is committed as a conservative
who stood on a conservative manifesto in
2017 to delivering on the vote of the
British people in 2016 and to delivering
a bright future for this country
[Applause]
Thank You Speaker I rise to not only
thank my rights of a friend for a loyal
service as Prime Minister over the last
three years but also for her 33 years in
public service which is a record to be
proud of but also to thank her for her
personal support in helping me get my
private member's bill but homelessness
reduction Act that's why I write on a
friend agree with me that is far better
to help people prevent people from
becoming homeless to use the taxation
system to combat obesity and to prevent
people from smoking in the first place
does she agree with me the prevention is
far better than a cure can I say two
more friends can I thank him for all the
work that he did on his homelessness
reduction Act can I also say crucially
we are actually seeing that act having
an impact and that is so important for
people who are benefiting from the work
that he did
he's been worked doing a lot of work I
know as part of the smoking and health a
PPG and I agree that we do need to start
viewing health as an asset to protect
throughout our lives that's why we've
taken bold action on smoking and on
childhood obesity and I'm proud that
we've delivered the biggest-ever cash
boost in the history of the National
Health Service but also a long-term plan
that as my honourable friend and says
we'll focus on prevention a prevention
also focusing on cancer care in mental
health but making sure that we are
trying to ensure that people do not get
into the situation where they are in
that ill health in the first place
preventing smoking preventing obesity
are key parts for better lives for
people in the future Jeremy Corby
Thank You mr. speaker today today marks
the final day in office for the Prime
Minister and I pay tribute to her sense
of public duty public service should
always be recognized being an MP a
minister or indeed a prime minister is
an honor that brings with it huge
responsibility and huge pressures both
personally and I'm sure the Prime
Minister and probably the whole house
would agree on those very closest to us
who often are not able to answer back
for the criticisms made against them so
I hope mr. speaker that she has a
marginally more relaxing time on the
back branches and perhaps like the
Chancellor even helping me to oppose the
reckless plans of her successor
[Music]
mr. speaker
mr. speaker if I may continue in the
[Applause]
I'm glad the opposite and I'm glad the
government parties in such good heart
today mr. speaker for tomorrow they
won't be mr. speaker in the last three
years in the last three years child
poverty has gone up pensioner poverty
has gone up in work poverty has gone
violent crime has gone NHS waiting times
have gone our school class sizes of
Ghana homelessness has gone up food bank
use has gone up does the Prime Minister
have any regrets about any of those
things I've just said right honourable
gentlemen
it's very good to see the Conservative
Party in good harped is more than I can
say for the neighbourhood
but let me just tell the right
honourable gentleman that it just says
I'm the right honourable gentleman about
my record over the last three years and
how I measure my record over the last
three years it's in the opportunity for
every child who is now in a better
school it's in the comfort for every
person who now has a job for the first
time
it's in the hope of every disadvantaged
young person now able to go to
university and it's in the joy of every
couple who can now move into their own
home
[Music]
at its heart politics isn't about
exchanges across these dispatch boxes
know about eloquent speeches or media
headlines politics is about the
difference we make every day to the peak
lives of people up and down this country
they are our reason for being here and
we should never forget it politics is
about real-life politics is about what
people suffer in their ordinary lives
and I didn't mention that per-pupil
school funding has gone down police
numbers are down GP numbers are falling
in the 2000 in the 2017 conservative
manifesto the Prime Minister promised
that no school would have its budget
cuts and that they would perfect protect
TV licences for the over 75 and Parv
rough sleeping which of these pledges is
the Prime Minister most sorry has not
been achieved he spent some time reading
the Conservative Party manifesto in 2017
had he read it properly he's not being
known always for reading the documents
that he stands up early he'd have said
we did make a pledge on rough sleeping
to half rough sleeping by 2022 and to
stop rough sleeping by 2027 I'm pleased
to say that in the last year we have
seen we have seen rough sleeping
and particularly rough sleeping going
down in those areas where this
government has been taking action
generally Gorby I don't quite know where
the primacy gets our figures from on
rough sleeping all I know is that I
travel around this country I travel
around this country just like other
members of this house and I talk to
people who have had a disaster in their
lives and end up rough sleeping
we are the fifth richest country in the
world it is surely wrong that anyone
should end up sleeping on the streets of
this country we can and should do
something about it mr. speaker I've
often disagreed with the Prime Minister
and have many criticisms of her policies
however I welcomed the reduction in the
stake on fixed odds betting terminals
the adoption of the children's funeral
fund and scrapping employment tribunal
fees which of these policies is the
Prime Minister most proud of I'm proud
of all the policies that we have
introduced had been improving people's
lives I'm proud of the fact that through
the balanced management of the economy
that we have done we now see more people
in work in this country I'm proud of the
fact there are more children including
outstanding schools I'm proud of the
fact that the obtainment gap between the
disadvantaged and the advantage has been
narrowed under this government and I'm
proud of the fact that we are putting
the biggest cash boost in its history
into our national health service we are
ensuring that the National Health
Service the most beloved institution in
this country will be there for people
into the future this is a Conservative
government of my government delivering
on the things that matter to people in
their day-to-day lives speak of the
Prime Minister may have noticed that
none of those things that I mentioned
were actually in the Conservative Party
manifesto in 2017 but every one of them
was a Labour pledge in 2000
on brexit the Prime Minister's own red
lines ruled out any sensible compromise
deal only after she had missed her own
deadline to leave did the Prime Minister
even begin to shift her position but by
then she no longer had the authority to
deliver her successor has no mandate at
all does she have confidence that the
Honorable right honourable member for
Oxbridge will succeed where she has not
I work tirelessly to get a good deal for
the UK and I also worked hard to get
that deal through this Parliament I
voted for the deal what did the right
honourable gentleman do he voted against
a deal he voted to make no deal more
likely and when there was a prospect of
reaching consensus across this house the
right honourable gentleman walked away
[Applause]
every stage his only interest has been
playing party politics
frankly he should be ashamed of himself
we've had three years of bungled
negotiations if we now have the
spectacle of a prime minister coming
into office with no electoral mandate
looking for a brexit deal that has been
ruled out by the European Union or in
the case of a No Deal ruled out by the
majority in this house and by anyone
that understands the dangers to the
British economy of a No Deal
the next Prime Minister thought the Isle
of Man was in the European Union and
that the European Union made rules about
kippers that in fact were made by the
government that he was part of he also
said the UK could secure tariff free
trade through article 24 of the general
agreement on tariffs and trade despite
the trade secretary attorney-general
governor of the Bank of England all
confirming that is not possible at the
start of 2018 the it's coming don't
worry
[Music]
at the start of 2018 mr. speaker the
Prime Minister herself set up a new unit
to counter fake news charged with
combating this information how
successful does she think that's been I
have to say to the right honourable
gentleman that I I fear that our success
hasn't been what we what we wanted it to
be from the amount of fake news and fake
information he uses at that dispatch
[Applause]
what maybe maybe mr. speaker she can
have a word with her successor on the
way out but let me conclude by welcoming
some
fortunately mr. speaker let me conclude
by welcoming some of the Prime
Minister's notable u-turns over the last
couple of years the cruel dementia tax
was scrapped plans to bring crack
grammar schools were ditched the threats
of the pensions triple lock was
abandoned withdrawal of the winter fuel
payments was dumped the pledge to bring
back foxhunting was dropped and they
bend their plan to end universal school
Maat free school meals for five to seven
year olds the Prime Minister has dumped
her own manifesto given that her
successor has no mandate from the people
no mandate of which to move into office
doesn't she agree the best thing the
right honourable member for Oxbridge
could do later on today when he takes
office is to call a general election and
let the people decide their future
[Music]
[Applause]
my first answer to the right honourable
gentleman is no and if he wants to talk
about people ducking Manifesto
commitments and commitments made during
a general election campaign can we
remember what the Labour Party's right
honourable gentleman said about student
debt
[Applause]
What did he say during the general
election he was committed to Trident
what does he say after the general
election no he's not committed to
Trident at all he has broken promise
after promise to the people of this
country but I say to the right
honourable gentleman I say to the right
honorable gentleman as this is the last
time that we will have this exchange
across these dispatch boxes
[Applause]
I was going to say that is the strength
of our British democracy that the Prime
Minister and the leader of the
Opposition have these exchanges across
their dispatch boxes every week at two
swords length no water is sought and
none is given and that's as it should be
in our adversarial parliamentary
democracy but he and I have very
different people and with very very very
different politicians I think we
approach the issues we face in this
country in different ways I have spent
all but one of my years in this house on
the front bench trying to implement the
policies I believe in he has spent most
of his time on the back benches
campaigning for what he believes in
often against his own party but what I
think we both have in common is a
commitment to our constituencies I saw
that after the terrorist attack in
Finsbury Park mosque in his constituency
and but perhaps like we just finished my
exchange with him by saying this as a
party leader who has accepted when her
time was up perhaps the time is now for
him to do the same
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there be yes don't be shy mr. Davis
assert yourself man we must hear from
you thank you very much mr. speaker
I first met the Honourable member for
Maidenhead when she came campaigning
with me invariably in the early in the
very difficult days the dark days of the
earth of the late 1990s she's been a
great friend of Wales ever since then
yeah only recently her government has
approved the end of the tolls on the m4
and a number of other great issues for
Wales I can I ask the they all remember
the Prime Minister right on remember the
Prime Minister to encourage her
successor to bring forward a bill to
extend the general election franchise to
all British citizens living overseas
whether it's a wide diaspora of Welsh I
thank my honourable friend for his
remark and I thank him also for
highlighting the work that the
government has done in Wales I would add
to that that there are over 95,000
people in Wales who had a pay rise this
year as a result of national living wage
and we've seen employment in Wales rise
567 thousand since 2010 so we have
indeed seen conservatives delivering for
Wales I know the concern there is about
the franchise issues for overseas voters
and I'm sure that is something that my
successor will wish to look at but could
I also say to my honourable friend that
I discovered I discovered a new part of
his his past recently which is that I
believe I believe he was once I believe
he was once the bodyguard to the
legendary Hollywood actress Lauren
Bacall
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to say mr. speaker I think his
red face tells us all
in Blackford
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker Prime Minister it
is fair to say that we have had our
differences that does not often been a
shared meeting of minds
however with the Prime Minister standing
down today the time for holding the
Prime Minister to account has passed mr.
speaker the burdens of office are
considerable the loneliness of
leadership can be starred wealth there
are times we have clashed on points a
political difference equally we have
stood together when it has been right to
do so over Salisbury and over the threat
to the UK's national unity the Prime
Minister has made sure that opposition
leaders were informed at key moments in
national security and in particular her
chief of staff Gavin Burrell has always
sought to make sure that I was kept
informed of important developments Prime
Minister I wish you and Philip all the
best for the future as the Prime
Minister departs is she confident that
the office of Prime Minister can be
upheld by her flagrant successor
can I first of all say can I first of
all thank the right honourable gentleman
for his remarks he's absolutely right he
and I are the difference of opinion on
some on some key issues but I've been
grateful for the position that the SNP
has taken on some of those key issues of
national security when it has stood
alongside the government as we have
faced the actions of our enemy and can I
also say to the to the right honourable
gentleman that I understand the point
that he has made about keeping
opposition leaders in in touch with
things that have that have taken place
and I would also like to take this
opportunity mr. speaker to pay tribute
to Gavin Barwell who was a first class
first class member of this house a first
class minister and has been an
absolutely first-class chief of staff
and in answer to the right honourable
gentleman's question yes I congratulate
my right honourable friend a four-out
winning the conservative leadership
election he will take over as Prime
Minister and I look forward to a
first-class Conservative government
under his leadership delivering for the
whole of the United Kingdom mr. speaker
the prime minister-elect has no mandate
in Scotland he has no mandate from the
people the government he is busy forming
has no mandate in Scotland mr. speaker
Scotland deserves better
shows 60% of people in Scotland are
dismayed and disappointed by the new
Prime Minister Prime Minister we on
these benches have tabled an LED motion
with friends from
rejecting this house being shut down
before November following Parliament's
order harming message and last week's
vote can I invite the Prime Minister and
one of her first actions as a backbench
MP to sign our leader motion and join
efforts to stop the suspension of
parliament under any circumstances
I say can I say to the right honorable
gentleman as I said as I said in answer
to his first question I accepted that he
and I do have differences on a number of
issues we both I think we both have a
passion for delivering for the people of
Scotland I want to do that with Scotland
as part of the United Kingdom he wants
to take Scotland out of the out of the
United Kingdom and can I say to him that
we what we do have in this in this
government is a mandate from the people
to form a government of this country
that's how we run things in the
parliamentary democracy in the
parliamentary democracy that we have
here in this in this country we also
have a mandate from the people to
deliver on the result of the 2016
referendum and if he's so interested in
delivering on mandates of the British
people he should have voted for the deal
and take us out of the EU this is
Pauline Latham
[Music]
that's racial project running through my
constituency which would create an
off-road cycle way between Derby and
ballet providing an alternative
commuting routes encouraging tourism in
clergy cycling amongst young and
improves the health of the local
population
that's the Prime Minister agree with me
that more funding should be made
available to support this and of the
similar projects yeah but can I
recognize the importance of increasing
cycling and walking this is this is
important for people's health it's
important for the local environment and
schemes like the Durbin Fanny cycleway
provides significant benefit to the
local economy as well as to health and
the environment so we have doubled our
spending on cycling and walking in
England and local cycling and walking
infrastructure plan enables local
authorities to take a strategic approach
to planning improvements in their local
cycling and walking and to integrate
those into wider plans for transport and
economic development and I'm sure this
is an issue that will continue to be
supported by conservatives in government
mr. speaker in Newcastle the Prime
Minister's departure invokes neither the
despair of a rapper benitez know yet the
joy of a Mike Ashley and she may take
comfort from that but as she considers
her choices House of Lords dignified
retirement working with her successor
can I ask her to work to bring dignity
and choice to others she is a waspy
women woman will she dedicate her prime
ministerial retirement to justice for
all was first of all we have put a
billion pounds extra into the pension
system recognizing concerns that were
expressed by women about the changes to
pensions but she references what I'm
going to be doing in the future I
thought I drew her to be making that
very clear I will be continuing in this
house as the Member of Parliament for
Maidenhead
closed question Michael fabricant 14 sir
I'm sure my little friend will won't
join me in saying how pleased I am with
the economic growth that we've seen in
the West Midlands combined authorities
area outputs increased 27 percent over
five years productivity increased at
twice the national rate last year and
employment has increased since 2011 and
I think that the West Midlands combined
Authority shows precisely what a local
visible innovative leadership can do and
how it could be the key to building a
strong economy and a fairer society
Michael fabrikam with the prime
minister's active encouragement the
mayor of the West Midlands was elected
in May 2017 and she has supported him
and the region ever since over 2 billion
pounds mr. speaker has been given to the
region by the Prime Minister in form of
grants and guarantees for transport and
so many other worthwhile projects so on
behalf of the people of the West
Midlands may I thank her and may I also
ask that she continues in Parliament as
a strong advocate for local devolution
[Applause]
the conversation I had with anji street
when I was encouraging him to stand for
Merrill tea of the West Midlands and I'm
very pleased that he did and he has been
delivering for the people of the West
Midlands ever since his election I also
thank my honorable friend for
highlighting the accent of work that we
have done for the West Midlands
government working with that combined
Authority shows the benefits of the very
local devolution that my honourable
friend has referred to and I think this
is a very good example of what that
innovative leadership that visionary
leadership can do at a local level and
improving the lives of people in
brennidon
mr. speaker outgoing American presidents
get to pardon anybody they want if she
could
would she pardon her successor for
sabotaging her Premiership purely for
his own personal ambition
I'd say to the Honorable Jen can I say
to the Honorable gentleman that my
successor will continue to deliver the
conservative policies that have improved
the lives of people up and down this
country since we were elected into a
coalition government in 2010 there is a
long list of improvements that have
taken place in people's lives and I look
forward I look forward on the back
benches to giving my full support to the
next prime minister as he takes us
forward delivering on brexit and
continuing to deliver on those
conservative policies can I thank my
right honorable friend for the way in
which he has conducted herself as Prime
Minister Risha with a dignified way in
which he has approached the job and her
responsibilities can I ask her to
reflect on the fact that when we both
first joined the government in 2010 for
every four pounds the government was
spending we were borrowing one pound and
she leaves office today for every 34
pounds the government spends we're
borrowing one she has left an economy
that is in a much more stable position
[Applause]
to do that to do that she has had to
make some very very difficult choices
and choices we may not have wanted to
make but we've got the economy on sound
footing
well can I can I thank my right
honourable friend for pointing out that
facts about a government borrowing and
for highlighting the work that we have
done or for the economy delivering that
balanced approach and I'd like to thank
my right honorable friend the Chancellor
for the work that he has done in
delivering that what does that mean it
means borrowing at its lowest level for
17 years it means the lowest
unemployment since the 1970s wages
growing at their fastest time in a
decade and debt falling that's what my
government has delivered more jobs
healthier finances and an economy fit
for the future Thank You mr. speaker
the Education Select Committee published
his report on Friday stating that the
government should urgently address
underfunding in further education by
increasing the amount 4000-pound per
student to four thousand and seven
hundred sixty pounds what the problem is
to agree that raising the rate will
benefit the excellent bulge of six from
college in my constituency as well as
many other colleges which are also under
severe financial pressure some of which
are actually going under lady that
obviously always look at select
committee reports with care but actually
they're my commission to review the
order of you about post educate post 18
funding in education that was review has
been very clear that more money needs to
go into further education and more money
into six forms I want to see that
happening indeed I think the Justice
just as my government has given a
priority to the National Health Service
in looking at funding for the future the
next government should give a priority
to education so that we can see that
money going into Fe in six forms and
ensuring that for every young person
there is an avenue through education and
training that suits them that suits
their talents and gives them the best
opportunities for their future mr.
speaker the Prime Minister has always
been a great champion of victims of
domestic violence as Prime Minister
Anders Home Secretary and she's directed
many many millions of pounds during her
time into improving those support
services but does she agree with me
there is still much more work
be done in terms of prevention and early
intervention and the ongoing skepticism
that still greets many victims when they
report violence can I can I thank my
humble friend for raising a very
important issue and also thank her for
the work that I know she did in her
legal practice prior to coming into this
house with for the victims of domestic
violence this is a very important issue
I'm proud of the domestic abuse bill
that has been introduced in this house
and I look forward to the debates on
that bill as it goes through its time in
Parliament it but my old friend is
absolutely right
we do need to continue the focus to
continue making sure that we're working
on prevention and continuing to raise
awareness we must ensure that domestic
violence is seen for what it is these
are criminal acts that are being
perpetrated and they should not be
brushed under the carpet people should
not just say oh it's something that
happens behind closed doors or just a
domestic we need to take domestic
violence very seriously we need to
ensure that we take the appropriate
action for the pro' in relation to the
perpetrators but also that victims are
given support and that they feel
confident and able to come forward at
the earliest opportunity
to report what has happened to them
Thank You mr. speaker my constituent the
way for captain Dean's crafting our
brave experienced and decorated soldier
was the UK military for 29 years and
January 2018 he was killed while serving
an arai believed to be by a fort worth
driven by US soldiers 18 months later
captain spray fatigues family have stole
not an answer as to how he came to his
day his death has not been fully
investigated and those driving the truck
have not been brought to justice
candy p.m. ensure that there will be a
continuing investigation into the cause
of his death
can I say to your champion obviously
he's raised an issue of great concern
and I'm sure it will be of concern to
members across this house and and of
course to his to family of his
constituent can I say to him that I will
ensure that the Ministry of Defence
provides a response to him on this issue
Bert
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker could I could I
thank my right honourable friend for her
work in supporting and overseeing the
Global Health Program that the United
Kingdom delivers overseas particularly
vaccinations and most notably polio
eradication vaccinations for which she
has herself been internationally
recognized and which has saved and
safeguarded millions of children's lives
across the world does she agree with me
that the need to combat misinformation
about vaccinations as perhaps now as
important as it ever has been and would
she in her memo to her successor just
note the importance of this program and
also the continuing need for a
self-standing department for
international development for his and
his reference to the work on polio
enables me to congratulate and commend
the work that's been done my main
constituent Judas diamond with Rotary
International in their work against
against polio can I also say to him that
the the it is important that we do
combat the disinformation about
vaccinations and ensure that people are
willing to have those vaccinations which
will change their lives which will
ensure that they can lead healthy lives
rather than succumbing to two diseases
and conditions that can have an impact
on their lives can I also say to him I'm
proud of the fact that we have a
department for international development
I'm proud of the fact that we've
legislated for naught point seven
percent of gni to be spent on
development aid overseas that is an
important element of global Britain an
important element of our standing in the
world
Tom Bray Thank You mr. speaker last
Friday I had the honour of witnessing
the presentation of the lesion donor to
Helen aldwyck old Winkle who is a
constituent for the work that she did at
Bletchley Park as a codebreaker in World
War two she played a critical role in
defeating the most disgusting fascist
ideology so will the Prime Minister on
her last day at the despatch-box join me
in saying that all politicians should
remember the common goals which United
people like
Helen and they must never resort to nor
fail to call out nationalistic rhetoric
which paints others as enemies
victimizes minorities or espouses racism
and if they do they are neither fit to
be a president nor a prime minister can
I say to the right honourable gentleman
the - I have said on a number of
occasions in the past it behooves all of
us as politicians indeed all in public
life to be careful about the language we
use and to ensure that we give a very
clear message that there is no place in
our society for racists really excuse me
for a sysm or for hate crime and we
should all act to ensure that we deliver
on those sentiments can I also say to
him to thank Helen for her work at
Bletchley Park on all those who worked
at Bletchley Park unsung for some
considerable time they played an
absolutely crucial part in our ability
to defeat fascism in the in the Second
World War and we should be very proud of
the work that they did and I'm grateful
for the opportunity he's given for this
house to celebrate it each Simpson can I
begin mr. speaker by commending the
Prime Minister her term of office for
her stamina and her courage
whatever our views on brexit and other
issues and the support that she received
from her husband Philip
for many of us our husbands wives
partners are the unsung heroes may I now
ask her a specific question she is going
to the palace this afternoon and we
assume that she's going to recommend
that the right honourable member for
Oxbridge succeeds her as Prime Minister
but can she tell the house one piece of
real hard advice that she would like to
give him on being Prime Minister
[Music]
mr. speaker can I say a number of my
honourable right honourable friends from
a sedentary position are suggesting that
advice should be to read my honorable
friends summer reading list like I also
say to him that he's given me an
opportunity for doing something which I
suspect many on my side may not thank me
for but I'm taking I'm taking a lead
from you mr. speaker in saying that I'm
very pleased to be able to see my
husband in the gallery today
very okay Thank You mr. speaker
obviously disagree with the Prime
Minister on many aspects of policy in
the work she's done over the last few
years both as Prime Minister of Home
Secretary but it would be wrong not to
commend the Prime Minister on the
phenomenal work she's done on bringing
forward the issue of modern slavery into
a community and so can I congratulate
her on that but in doing that there are
still many issues and many challenges
with respect to this that the faces can
I just ask the prime minister last year
as part of government policy we locked
up 507 potential victims of modern
slavery as immigration offenders that
can't be right
and surely we need a change of public
policy to treat them as victims not as
criminals for his remarks and I also
thank him for the work that he has done
on this issue of modern slavery too
because it's one on which he and I had
spoken over on a number of occasions
over the years and he has been a great
champion of this issue as well as he
will know in the modern slavery Act that
we passed in 2015 we did take action to
in relation to those individuals who
could find themselves as the at the
receiving end of criminal charges as a
result but effectively because they had
been forced to act in that way because
of modern slavery and that was that was
dealt with in that issue we have been
looking at how we deal with victims I
cannot the referral mechanism and it is
important we've had an independent
review of the modern slavery act that
has proposed an updated number of
recommendations for improving the way in
which victims are treated and we will be
taking most of those recommendations
onboard Dame Caroline Spellman and
further to the Honorable gentleman's
mention of modern-day slavery I think
it's right to record that my right
honourable friend has long and
distinguished service in this house both
in government and in opposition but her
commitment to public service has been
out Stern
her vision and determination to bring
forward legislation against modern-day
slavery we led the world so I hope that
my right horrible friend will continue
her fight against slavery with us from
the back benches so that we stamp out
this evil scourge together and I look
forward to joining her on the back
benches and continuing to campaign on
this issue and I also would pay tribute
to her for the work that she has done on
this issue she's right it is an absolute
scourge we must continue to fight it and
we must continue to raise awareness of
it because there are too many people
today in this country not trafficked
into this country but British citizens
who find themselves taken into effective
slavery we must raise awareness of this
and we must constantly work to combat it
and to end it Sweeny the Prime Minister
has often spoken about the need for an
industrial strategy during her time in
office but this in rowlocks really works
in spring burn effectually known as the
Kali will be closed by its asset
stripping German or neva Tara's on
Freddy ending 163 years of engineering
excellence and the jobs of 200 skilled
workers Shane the Scottish and UK
government support failed to intervene
to save the strategic site since the
closure was announced late last year
well the work force has been left
devastated even though the Prime
Minister is losing Rowan job today it's
not too late for her to act now and to
destruct the government to do everything
it can to find a way to save these vital
jobs and there's a store it railway
works was she at least commit to doing
that
the Honorable gentleman I recognize the
concern that he's showing for his
constituency and the worry and concern
that there is for those people who are
employed in the in the business that he
has that he has referred to of course
whenever we see closures or factories
closures of industrial sites government
does act to ensure that support is
available for those who do find
themselves losing their jobs should that
be the case but can I also say to the
honourable gentleman he says that I said
that we I talked of having a modern
industrial sorry we have a modern
industrial strategy it is a modern
industrial strategy which is setting
setting essentially setting the
background and the framework which will
enable the economy of the United Kingdom
to be the economy for the 21st century
Charles Walker Thank You mr. speaker
you are in no doubt mr. speaker that I
think the Prime Minister is a thoroughly
good egg and it's been an absolute
privilege to serve on the back benches
with her misters mr. speaker this Prime
Minister's commitment to mental health
has been simply fantastic
it was fantastic where she was the Home
Secretary and fantastic as Prime
Minister the Stevenson farmer review
into workplace mental health so Symons
Wesley review into the 1983 Mental
Health Act her commitment to reducing
the tragedy of suicide and putting her
office behind that and the introduction
of places of safety for people
experiencing a mental health crisis Mr
Speaker we have been filling the Prime
Minister's dharia with future
commitments as she authors the next
chapter of her political life but can
she find space for a few more paragraphs
on mental health
can I thank our girlfriend for for his
intervention his question can I also
thank him and my right honourable friend
the Manchester man and mushroom for the
dignified way in which they conducted
the Conservative Party leadership
election he has been an advocate for
government doing more mental health for
his time during his time in this house
and he has championed the need for us to
do more on mental health I want to
continue to ensuring to ensure that we
do indeed take forward we've we have set
the record in putting that record
funding into mental health in having
those essential review Stevenson farmer
and so Simon Wesley's review we now need
to ensure that we implement the
proposals that we take this forward
because if we do so then we will make a
significant improvement in the lives of
those people with mental health problems
I bet this vegan professor John Snowden
of Sheffield Hollinger University
Hospital has just received a top NHS
award for pioneering work on stem cell
transplantation for MS sufferers mr.
speaker I'd like to declare my own
personal interest in this and that John
Snowden and his excellent team were
responsible for my own transplant last
year for a multiple myeloma a form of
blood cancer will she now given
assurance as she steps down as Prime
Minister but remains an MP that she
won't for a support any form of brexit
which prevents john snowden continuing
to work with his EU colleagues on the
board of the European Society for blood
and marrow transportation which will
continue to advance this treatment for
patients with myeloma ms and leukemia
and I say to the Honorable gentlemen the
first of all I commend the individual
that he's that he's referred to for the
work that he has been doing I'm not
aware of the particular organization
that he has referred to of which the
consultant he's referred to is a member
but can I just say to the Honorable
gentleman that I do want to see a
relationship between the United Kingdom
of the European Union in the future that
enables our scientists enables our
academics to continue to work with those
in the EU as well as those around the
rest of the world to do the pioneering
work which is the honourable gentleman
has said from his own experience is
changing people's lives and improving
those lives for the better
oh yes a singular denizen of the house
Sir John Hay promised when I first
encountered the bonding pitch and
blinding light of solitary life together
in 1997 and since then over many tests
I've endured some defeats and enjoyed
many victories as she reflects on her
innings on the front bench will she'd
counts as amongst her greatest
treatments the falling number of
worklist households which which succor
personal responsibility secure family
stability and nurture communal pride
will she continue that work and in doing
so unite the whole house in that mission
thank my right honourable Frank I also
thank my right honourable friend for all
the work that we did together when he
was a home office minister he worked
very hard to ensure that what I believe
is is extremely important and pioneering
piece of legislation the Investigatory
Powers Act went through this went
through this house and I'm very happy to
welcome the fact that we now have that
low number of worklist households in
this country we all know that children
brought up in a household where there is
work are more likely to do better at
school and more likely to succeed
further in their own lives it's an
important aid to reduce the number of
worklist households and one that I would
have hoped could be accepted and
championed across this whole house
Osteen Thank You mr. speaker and can I
start by associating myself completely
with the final answer the Prime Minister
gave to the leader of the Opposition
about his need to consider his future
and can I tell you this as well can I
tell you this as well it's absolutely
clear to me that the vast majority of
like Greenpeace agree with her too
[Applause]
mr. speaker mr. speaker hundreds of
people hundreds of people hundreds of
people come to my community meetings in
the last few weeks so worried about
anti-social behavior their word about
car crime that worried about burglaries
and they're worried about violent crime
too they want more police on the streets
and they want more criminals locked up
so will she
urge her successor to make sure West
Midlands Police gets all the support it
needs to keep people in Dudley safe can
I can I can I first of all congratulate
the Honorable gentleman his appointment
as trade envoy to Israel I think he's
done and he's done a lot of work on
anti-semitism and should be
congratulated for that work too we have
and on if I may on we have been ensuring
that we have been putting more money
into police forces around a billion
pounds extra is available to police
forces this this year and many police
forces around the country are recruiting
more officers but can I say in the theme
that the Honorable gentleman started in
his question it is therefore I would
imagine to him and to others a great
matter of sadness that his right
honourable friend the leader of the
Opposition took the Labor Party through
voting against extra money for the
police and against extra powers for the
race Victoria Prentiss
mr. speaker 31 people were killed in Eid
Lib yesterday and many tens of thousands
of people displaced again I would like
to thank the Prime Minister for her
personal commitment to Syria and for
international development more widely
and I would like her to join with me and
reassuring the people of Syria
that all of us here will continue to
remember them my honourable friend first
of all I commend what the work that she
did in setting up singing for Syria
which has been raising funds for people
in in Syria and the commitment that she
has shown to the people of Syria we
remain and the Conservative government
will remain committed to working for a
political solution in Syria that can
provide the stability and security that
the people of Syria deserve
Nigel dogs mr. speaker and can I join
with others in thanking the prime
minister for her years of public service
as Home Secretary and as Prime Minister
and the thoroughly decent and dedicated
honorable way she's kind at all of her
duties and this very courteous and
proper way that she's had in her
dealings with us as a party and working
together we have ensured that there
actually is a conservative and unionist
government of the United Kingdom
which will please many in this house and
I'll also please liber members by saying
that we have ensured that there's no
early general election
[Applause]
now that the Prime Minister Nouri that
the Prime Minister has more time on her
hands with her dear husband Philip I
urge you to come to Northern Ireland and
avail of the many working opportunities
there she will have seen the wonderful
she will have seen the wonderful Open
Championship this weekend in royal
Portrush credit to Northern Ireland a
credit to the United Kingdom the warm
hospitality of the people of Northern
Ireland show and it is very open to her
as well honorable gentleman and thank
him for the discussions that we have had
and the support that he has continued to
give to the conservative and unionist
party so that there is a conservative
and unionist government in this country
can I thank him for the warm welcome
that he has given - for me - and Philip
to Northern Ireland I've enjoyed my
visits to Northern Ireland but I'd like
to congratulate all those in Northern
Ireland involved in putting on the Open
Championship at Portrush with the slight
issue with the weather I think which
which may have favored those who came
close to the top of the of the
championship but but it was an excellent
championship put on and I think many
many people will have seen the delights
and benefits of Northern Ireland when
they attended that to that event Jacob
Riis mall thank you
as somebody who has not invariably seen
eye-to-eye with the Prime Minister may I
marry thank her for her remarkable
public service and person and for
sharing that highest of virtues a sense
of duty and on top of that being willing
to deal with people who must on
occasions have been annoying to her with
enormous courtesy mr. speaker on behalf
of many people may I thank the Prime
Minister
[Applause]
can I say the Honorable gentleman's
voice carries I was able to hear his
question but I am at least as interested
to hear the answer the Prime Minister Mr
Speaker can I thank my honourable friend
for his remarks and can I say to him
that the point of this place is about
debate and argument and discussion about
the issues that we all believe and that
matter to us all that so so passionately
and those debates and discussions are
best held when they are held with
respect and courtesy and I thank thank
my honourable friend for the courtesy
that he had shown to me in our
discussions together and I look forward
to probably continuing some of those
discussions when I joined him on the
back benches
J Swinson Thank You mr. speaker when I
think of girls growing up in eastern
Barton sure it is inspiring for them to
see women in positions of power whether
that's as First Minister of Scotland or
as Prime Minister of our United Kingdom
can I ask the Prime Minister what advice
she has for women across the country on
how to deal with those men who think
they could do a better job but are not
prepared to do the actual work
[Applause]
I think by my advice to all women is
actually be true to yourself persevere
keep going and be true to the vision
that you are working for but can I
congratulate the right honourable lady
of her election as leader of her party
I'm pleased also that we have a member
representing a Scottish constituency who
is a leader of a United Kingdom party
and I think it goes to show we are one
United Kingdom and MPs from the four
nations of our union sit in this house
on the basis of equality him I also say
to the Honourable lady that I
congratulate her on becoming the first
woman I believe to lead the the Liberal
Party and as I stand down I'm pleased to
be able to hand the baton on to another
female leader of a political party but
as you look around the chamber I have to
say we almost have a full set she's
referred and my party's had two women
leaders the Liberal Party now has a
woman leader the SNP has a woman leader
as they'll do the DUP applied and the
Greens have even even wait for it wait
for it
even even the independent chica group
change you pay or whatever they're
calling themselves this week
[Applause]
are now on to their second woman that
leader there's only one party in this
house letting the cider
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker
can I thank my right honorable friend
all she has done for women in
Parliament's and in this country from
co-founding women to wind to tackling
domestic abuse and modern slavery and
legislating to make our society more
equal
will she urged her successor to build on
her work and make Britain the best place
in the world to be a woman happy to to
urge that commitment for the future but
I think while real friends raising this
particular issue and I'm very pleased
that under my government we've seen the
gender pay gap at a record low we see in
female employment at a record high and a
record percentage of women on executive
boards and we're now seeing with our
women's empowerment roadmap we're
looking at how we can empower women in
this country from school to retirement I
want women in this country to feel that
there are no limits to how far they can
go and what they can do with their lives
we have disagreed on many things over
the years but the Prime Minister knows
that I have long respected her
resilience her commitment to public duty
and her seriousness and also her work on
the national security and I can reassure
her that there is much to be done from
the back benches but she will also know
that I said to her once that I believed
she was not the kind of person who would
take this country into a chaotic No Deal
not least because of the advice she had
had on the risks to our national
security I am fearful about her
successor so can she reassure me that
she really thinks in her heart that her
successor will take those national
security warnings as seriously as she
has and if he doesn't in October will
she speak out lady first of all I had
every confidence that my successor will
take all the issues that he needs to
look at in making these decisions and
others across government as seriously as
they need to be taken but can I also say
to her I'm sorry and I am going to have
I will say this she's absolutely right
that I've always said that I believe it
is better for this country to leave with
a good deal and I believe we negotiated
a good deal I voted three times in this
house for a good deal I spoke to the
right honourable lady about this about
this issue if she was so concerned about
the security aspect
she's short a voted for the deal
Dave Jerrel Gilliam
[Music]
mr. speaker the Prime Minister in every
aspect of her public life has put her
heart and soul into giving people the
best chance in life without
understanding autistic people and their
families which number 2.8 million in the
UK are all at risk of being isolated and
developing mental health problems in
thanking the Prime Minister for all the
work that she has done in furthering the
issues surrounding mental health and
removing the stigma can I ask her after
she has left the front bench to spend
more meaningful time with her husband
Philip if she will join the All Party
Parliamentary Group and become a
champion and advocate for autistic
people throughout the country and also
thank her for the groundbreaking work
that she did with the autism Act in 2009
and I think that it was that act helps
to raise people's awareness of the
issues of people on the autistic
spectrum and a great much greater
understanding of what we needed to do in
order to enable people with autism to
lead full filling lives can I also say
to her that I will there are many issues
that I want to take an interest in when
I'm on the back benches this is one and
wrong with the wider issue of mental
health that I want more want to continue
to to look at and I have committed to
taking the autism training that the
quarter group has made available for
members of parliament finally I call the
mother of the house Harriet Harman
it's always an historic moment when a
Prime Minister leaves office especially
when the country faces such difficult
times as we do ahead but her departure
marks another milestone because though
we're on to our 77th Prime Minister now
she is only the second woman ever to
have held that office and she put
tackling human trafficking and the
horrors of domestic violence as a
priority at the heart of her government
and can I say that in that respect her
legacy is secure because everyone in
this house backs that and we will all be
committed to taking that forward even
her harshest critics must recognize her
integrity her commitment to public
service her dedication to this country
and those are qualities that none of us
should ever take for granted but can I
just offer her a word of sisterly advice
sometimes you just have to be a bit more
careful when a man wants to hold your
hand
I thanked her for her service as our
prime minister and I sincerely wish her
all the very best for the future well
can I thank the right honourable lady
for her further question of course the
right honourable lady joined this house
in 1982 when there was a female prime
minister but very few women in this
house and she has played a very
important role and she could be proud of
the role that she played in ensuring
that more women came into this house as
labour members of parliament and she
started something which has started to
change the face of this house which has
been very important I of course came
here in 1997 as one of only 30
conservative women and indeed one Labour
Member of Parliament approached me to
encourage me to sign the private
member's bill list because he assumed as
always a woman I must have been a Labour
Member of Parliament but I'm also proud
I'm also glad to have played my part in
getting more women MPs in this house and
I'm sure that amongst the women in this
house today there is a future Prime
Minister maybe more than one day today
as I said earlier I will return to the
back benches and it will be my first
time in 21 years so it's gonna be quite
a change from standing here at the
despatch-box I'm told that over the last
three years I've answered over 4,500
questions over 140 hours in this house
more more than I might have expected mr.
speaker
[Music]
in future I look forward to asking the
questions but we are as the right
honorable lady has said living through
extraordinary political times this House
of Commons is rightly at the center of
those events and that's because of the
vital link between every single member
of this house and the communities the
Commons that we represent that's the
bedrock of our parliamentary democracy
and of our Liberty and each one of us
wherever we sit whatever we stand for
can take pride in that and that duty to
serve my constituents will remain my
greatest motivation
[Applause]